do you ever think I will I don't regret
saying it I've made a lot of mistakes
[Music]
you tell me if I'm getting too personal
but in 1976 you made an admission of
bisexuality what has been the response
particularly in the United States this
is supposed to be the great liberal
country in the whole world but I thought
unfortunately isn't how Democrats hang
but also one has to understand that a
lot of people don't understand a
situation as well yes that a lot of
people found it offensive and I was a
little angry at the time I also learned
a lot that people you can't shove things
in people's faces and expect them to
understand things for straightaway
maybe my ego was touched I thought
people would automatically accept but I
must admit I didn't realize what the
situation we might get me into and it
did get me into a situation
how rotten can you get baby face come on
no I'm a real tantrum galore this John
McEnroe's nothing towards me when I
haven't but I have a tantrum hey
everybody just runs away after ten
minutes I think where are they all they
just ignore me the perfect way to do
with me
Oh in this business you go crazy
sometimes I have great respect for me
but they don't hold back they're very
honest people you know they tell you
when they think something's wrong with
you they tell you they don't like
something and I'm being in that to loot
Rotter which I can be or what all the
time sometimes I've made a lot of
mistakes and been a real pig - people
have been horrible and had points in my
life where I was very happy but now I
don't think I'd change I think this I
think you can learn from those sort of
things I've been incredibly lucky to
have people to help me through the bad
times what did you say your name was
again
my name is Reginald Dwight Reginald
that's my granddad's name do you regret
changing your name do you ever think I
wish I knew
god I love changing my name I hated
being ridged white and loaded it I was
euphoric when I was became Elton John
because something Reginald was the name
my son didn't enjoy as a child red just
kind of sneaking back into my life a bit
now how I don't know I just feel a bit
reg like sometimes I don't mind the
weapon name red so much but in those
days it was Reginald and it's kind of up
it's just it's like naming a baby Oswald
or something like that he's come
how can you produce Abednego Oh Oswald
sorry all yours wars out there it's just
it seems crazy you're given a name you
have to be stuck with and if you don't
like it
I really couldn't wait to change my now
I'm thinking into changing my name to
Elton that's my name yeah
[Music]
it's time that you prepare the tour is
there some sort of anticipation that you
have some anxiety like okay I'm starting
yeah yeah yes I'm before it so if you
don't have that anxiety before you start
doing then you feel you're in real
trouble yeah I get real nervous before
the serving you too